okay so my name is Carl Steinbach I'm
the tech lead for the Hadoop platform
team at LinkedIn and today we're here to
talk about dr. elephant I'm just gonna
give a quick sort of like introduction
and a little bit about the motivations
for building this and then Fung she is
going to jump into the technical details
so I think to to sort of properly
understand dr. elephant you have to
understand you know where had you came
from it LinkedIn and where it's at now
and the problems that that created for
us so LinkedIn was a pretty early
adopter of Hadoop back in 2008 some
engineers heard about it and started
using it and the first cluster had 20
nodes there were only 10 users basically
limited to one group which was working
on a product at that time called people
you may know which is the true like
fundamental triangle closing app which
allows us to recommend new users and you
know it was really an engine of
LinkedIn's growth especially in the
early it is so back then 2008 you know
we had 10 users 10 production clusters
and the applications that people were
using were pretty much limited to
MapReduce and pig so like all good
things you know gets more popular over
time and that brings us to now so
running through the numbers we've gone
from one cluster to over 10 clusters a
handful of users to more than 1,000
users more than 10,000 nodes and I think
probably some of the more significant
factors have to do with really the the
diversity of the things that people are
doing on the clusters so we went from
sort of to supported you know engines or
analytic environments to a wide variety
and you know the open source ecosystem
keeps producing new and interesting
tools and engineers at LinkedIn keep
implementing new better tools so it's a
constant sort of struggle to keep up
with all of this so you know we learned
some things along the way we're getting
to the point where we've been doing this
for 10 years
and I think the one big observation is
that building big clusters is a
challenge you know if you read blog
posts about Hadoop or books all you're
going to hear about is the multi
thousand node clusters because no one
wants to talk about the median cluster
size which is really something more like
ten nodes so most of the vendors if you
look at their customer base it's people
running fairly small clusters and when
you go from let's say 500 nodes to 2,000
nodes there's a pretty big difference in
terms of the problems that you run into
and and the issues that you deal with
but I think somewhat surprisingly we
learned that well the solution to some
of the scaling issues in terms of
hardware is usually a challenge but you
know you can sort of press ahead with it
and get there scaling user productivity
especially when you have more than a
thousand users when you don't place
restrictions on the types of
applications that people are allowed to
run on the cluster or the types of
problems they're allowed to solve but
that's actually a much bigger problem
and it also turns out we discovered that
these two issues are actually kind of
tied to each other because a lot of
these tools that exist right now allow
you to get an answer to your question
but unless you invest a lot of time in
tuning the way that you ask that
question the amount of work that that
application can trigger on the cluster
may be really large or really wasteful
and while you know with effort a lot of
users are able to figure out like how do
i express my question in pig or hive or
MapReduce for that matter asking them to
then spend sometimes just as much time
figuring out how to tune that job to get
that answer efficiently is something
that you know users at that point don't
want to deal with and another problem is
that even if you tune it let's say on
Monday by Friday the job could be out of
tune so it's also sort of a constant tax
a maintenance burden placed on users so
the relation of course is that there's a
trade-off I mean you can either ask
people to spend time every week or every
month retuning their jobs besides which
learning to tune the job in the first
place and that's a
or you can just let them run untuned
jobs on the cluster and then have to
build bigger clusters dr. elephant
really is the goal is to find you an
ideal solution to this where we provide
a tool that helps users to tune their
jobs for them so we're able to get
efficient jobs that make the most of the
hardware resources that we're providing
while at the same time not squandering
the hours of developers and data
scientists and analysts so this point
I'm going to hand the mic over to funk
she who's going to give an in-depth look
at dr. elephant and how it's built
okay so uh I'm going to talk about talk
- I'll start with briefly what happened
is motivation and the history and then I
was going to give an overview of the of
the stories then its architecture and
then we're going to do a quick demo
about it and we've talked about some of
the service we built on top of town -
and how we use don't happen to help us
at LinkedIn and finally I will talk
about the some open source status and
the wrote pipes for the dot husband so I
will start with the motivation the first
thing is efficiency really matters so
each individual job or individual what
flow is very important to the overall
cluster utilization so if each draw in
the cluster save 10% in terminals memory
or safety you essentially you save 10%
of your cluster and the second thing is
people have different levels of Hadoop
skills so some some people are held as
they had to master but most people
doesn't have those how to master skills
so I do have thousands of parameters
that you can tune for your jobs and most
people don't know about that too much
and some people don't even know that
they are writing Hadoop drawers that may
have some
for the cluster so that's a pain point
for us as well and servicing is we find
people are making common mistakes that
can be solved by similar to Union tips
so people will come to us we as a Hadoop
team member we provide some user support
people come to us asking for how for
tips to tune their jobs and we find that
we are constantly giving the same tips
for every user for example suicides so
you told me have some small small small
file problems and so we suggest the user
to lie for a pumped-up resize and let
each task each mapper processing more
data or for example at the parallelism
and but by default hive may not use a
lot of reducers have you - a very big
Troy you your chrome may run forever and
it will be probably suggest the user to
pump the parallelism and increase the
number of reducers so that you drop can
run faster yeah so I'll keep talking
about that so here I pop out a few
pinpoints we have before we have dr.
happened and given this those cases we
feel that we should build a tool that we
can automate the tuning for every drove
and you know users percept perspective
we provide a service that you can they
can use the service together the
performance tank agnostic about their
workflows so that they can tune it
automatically we saw coming to ask and
coming to us and asked us to help them
tune it so we built not heaven and what
is starting to happen is they automated
drop performance monitoring and tuning
tool for Hadoop obvious initially we
only support MapReduce jobs and later we
added support for SPARC as well
it is the single host single process web
app that can run on any host BC in a
cluster as soon as your cancer - as soon
as the host has they access to top you
to the server or HDFS and it is a drop
based which means that it analyzed the
MapReduce job or
spark job right after it finishes so
usually when you're 12 finishes we see
in what minute you should be able to see
your trough performance report from the
heavens UI and we use it don't even use
a rule-based configure configurable
heuristics which means that we become
predefined a set of rules that will go
against each job and it is configurable
if so the rules we use are linked in to
analyze the job may not be suitable for
other companies in this case you can
extend you're building your own
heuristic we provide a set of interface
that you can just write some code and to
like build their own heuristics so it is
very flexible and a link in thought
heaven right now analyzed 100k drops per
day it write down all of our classes
clusters and we have hundreds of daily
users that use it to tune their
workflows so this is the architecture
about heaven so as I say it all happened
is a single process I have so here each
orange rectangle here is the inside that
happened and we will start with the top
level we have a drop generator that for
every one minute and will fetch a rest
call to the resource manager and cut a
list of drops that finishes within the
last one minutes so here are each
rectangle is triangle here is the
MapReduce drawing so in our case the
trout generator can swim a produced raw
and to spark off sparked off so we will
use MapReduce job as an example so the
top generator will pass the MapReduce
jobs to the met reduce factor in this
case each trout here it is simply the ID
and the MapReduce fetcher
will I fetch multiple calls to top
history store and get a detailed data
for that job for example I look at the
top metadata is Q is a crop name or
start ham and ham and like top
configurations if you also get like
counters or like time for each task so
after the MapReduce factor can already
require information from for this troll
from top you say server I will pass this
job to the MapReduce analyzer and we
have a set of rules configured inside
this analyzer i will go against the job
so in our case we have three rules
configured for the MapReduce job we have
one route to a true story and for this
draw we analyzed it gets a green score
for rule one and it got the principle of
a rule too but if you look at the rest
were for rue sory so let me give a
prints were we mean that this job is
school in thought happens perspective
this job is good it doesn't need any
tuning but if we cut a green a red
square it means that has some serious
problem and it should do some level of
tuning and in this case this draw since
it got a red squirrel so don't heaven
will assign a red to the drove and we'll
save the result in the mexico database
so this is the back end of dot heaven in
the front end a user can get a list out
see a list of jobs that don't have been
recently analyzed and the user can
search further so the top they concern
by drop ID or what flow ID so this is
how the user linking you don't happen
they just search for the already just
search for their work flow ID and get a
list of troughs in their work flow so I
will do some quick demos about heaven so
this is this UI page and for each draw
here is you can see you can see if you
have a list of rows and each row has a
result for this job and for this job we
can see that it has a red squirrel for
the mapper memory rule and it has a
orange score for the reducer memory rule
so since it has a red this draw will
kind of read
score which means said this drama needs
some tuning especially in this memory
settings so if you click on draw you go
to the detailed page that we will tell
you why we give this job like a for
example a orange score and and then we
will also provide some helper pages that
user can use to tune their job so here
if the user click is playing it will
really write to a helper page that user
know how they can how to like change the
drop parameters to make this job a
better way yeah so this is the teeth
health analyzes result for each for one
particular MapReduce job from here we
this is all the the mapper related
heuristic and you can see we have a beta
skill heuristic which me test if the if
this metric this drug has has some data
skill problem and we have a three C
heuristic which we test if the if this
be the matter if the memory in this draw
uses too much TC time and we have a time
related heuristic we will see if the Mac
reduced job Ryan if this the mapper for
this MapReduce trial run you know
reasonable run time range and we have a
memory heuristic we will see if the
mapper
uses reasonable memories and have a
spear heuristic or test if to see if the
if this Map Reduce browser used too much
data on disk and I will choose the time
where he receives for detailed demo so
this is like three analyze result for
three MapReduce job and this produced
raw kind of greens were in its matter
time because like this method this drove
the the member for this draw has
ten minutes so which means that we feel
okay this is the ideal time that we want
the job to be so we give them a green
score and for this MapReduce job like it
has 100 tasks but it's have 100 members
and each mapper runs more than two hours
and in this case we feel you should
probably tune your MapReduce job and
because like if the top run the mapper
runs too long it's bad for the oral
cluster scheduling so we feel in this
case you should like Tim your cue list
Rove and use more mappers
issuance last time and this is another
example in this in this case this method
runs the house like this draw has one
thousand and two hundred matters and it
each method I already ran only 20
seconds so this is also bad because
essentially you are wasting a lot of
resources so in this case we also assign
them assign this drove a red squirrel
and we will suggest the user to decrease
the number of tasks I probably just
probably like 100 never be enough so in
this case actually we can save a lot of
resource because the for each task it
has some time to like like invasive
scheduling on resources and this has
some tasks that have an initialization
time yes so and if the user so we
provide a very simple way we use the
configuration file the user can
configure the cutoff for the for the
heuristics but if the user doesn't
inside with that but you can also
instant the interface and build their
own heuristics if for other companies
yeah their understanding of my for time
may be different from us so in this case
you can feel free to write their own
heuristics
yeah so another feature about that
heaven is we want to understand why the
draw or wolf elope performance is
changing over time so as the data
science growing like the performance of
the Travis or will follow is also
changing so in our case what
so since don't have an analyzed area
trove and save the result in this
database so it's generally essentially
we have a history of the performance of
each drop or wolf elope so in this case
we can't display them and let the users
see the trend of their flow or crops or
workflows for example when you are
developing a flow don't have you can't
compare the time you have you make some
Coltrane you have a new round of your
workflow and you can go to the top
heaven and see the Steve CD of what flow
performance change between each runs in
this case you know if you make a better
trainer or not or like for example your
drop like you thought you were your
trouble runs five hours but today you're
your drama wolf alone runs ten hours you
also know why which drop costs the
problem uncle mm and see it as well or
we can even provide you some alerting
alert lurking feature means that you can
if you see if you began to a plot for
you you can see how your performance is
changing over time so you can even
predict that some problem will happen
soon so this is one of the feature the
graph intro and right now we also
support some other graph as well so in
this case like each row here is the is
the run of the wolf flow and you can see
you can like essentially you can see a
history of your flow runs
and finally I'm going to talk about the
service that we build on top of thought
happened on I think I'm I don't have
time to talk about the motivation but I
will just demo the feature so basically
we built a key reports that provide a
automated service for user to tune their
jobs
so if the user wants a drinking if the
user want their wool flow to right in
production we enforce a process that we
will like don't happen to approve the
user and letting the user to run their
workflow in production so what we do is
we do the JIRA posts we appeal that
automated report on top of the JIRA so a
user can file a ticket fellow to our
ticket and the user can count out
haven't officially you can add don't
happen to reveal their wool flow so if
that Heaven find the user call him he
will like Qaeda so it will cut the wool
flow ID from the firm that he can field
and rest cost to the real don't have
interest and get a list of the the
performance analytics report for this
war flow and we'll paste the result on
just commonly on the tear so if the user
comment 2000 and say don't have an
please review my wool flow and don't
heaven will come automatically like
several minutes later and paste the
result so in this case like if the the
the user can you start happen to
automatically review their wool flow and
if everything is good
if the everything is green and don't
happen we'll provide a grant the user
the privilege to run the workflow in
production this is how it you start
having a linking
so yes our meters release the service we
have a few user asking us if don't
happen is a real person
yeah actually it is the G opposed a
sister fake a connoisseur yeah and we
also have other service we build on top
of tower heaven for example daily report
so every day don't happen we'll report
or alert droves or for flows like our
culture a clusters mister worst
performance so we don't happen we'll
send a private email to this users
letting them tune their crops so this is
like the user will feel some users say
they feel ashamed because they're caused
by don't happen and if don't happen we
also like rip I monitored the what
fellow performance even if there has
been ragging on the production be fine
ok the introduction this dog has some
performance degradation don't heaven
will force the user to to production
review again basically the need to tuner
or flow again before they can run
production and we also had some cost to
serve analyzes service so the the page
has say saved in thought - theta base
it's used to analyze the cluster
utilization or resource consumption it's
actually we can Italy with separated by
organization so we know of each
organization use most of the resources
visit our cluster ok so finally I will
talk about some thoughts have an open
source status so we open source don't
happen in April 2000 as this year and
since then we have more than 10 people
contribute to thought - and we have more
than 40 commits and we have more than 50
topics in our user groups and there are
a lot of companies currently contributed
patches to thought happened including
Airbnb you know Airbnb has been running
thought Hefner in production and this
summer they heard a full-time inter and
focus on improving thought - and they
help us like if something thought
happened to understand more about their
airflow scheduler and we have Foursquare
screen this is the Chinese speak data
company and they help us translate all
the our documentation in Chinese and we
have PayPal and so PayPal has been also
has been running that happen in all of
their of d'argent clusters and we have
some other company as well so last slide
is the roadmap for thought haven't this
is the word that we are currently doing
to improve that happened
the first thing is beyond MapReduce to
have iron lattice so right now don't
happen focus more on the MapReduce job
and we want don't happen to understand
more about the higher-level knowledge
like Pig hive cascading so it can
provide some some tuning tips in the
wolf in their framework level and once
also you want support other schedulers
like Lucy and airflow we have a basic
support for Lucy and the airflow is
contributed by Airbnb and right now
there's active threat is causing the
ones right now we stop for MapReduce and
spara and they won't support the test as
well and another thing we are walking on
this corner is we want doing something
beyond the patch analysis so right now
don't have an analyzer child
right after I finish it so we won't
provide some real-time inside in well
the trough is running this is maybe
particularly useful for some
long-running applications like sparse
streaming also we are thinking about
like adding more analytics to fill the
trough so for example right now that if
the trough fails we display this is
stacked wrists but we don't have more
analysis on those stack traces but
actually we feel the step trees can be
very useful because there are a lot of
surface can be aggregated together and
to provide some similar solutions for
the office for similar start races so we
use some order called exception
fingerprinting
which essentially trying to get a
fingerprint for each exceptions and we
want to aggregate a similar staffing
together and in the future if we see a
similar exception again we can provide
some tuning tips for them like or in
this case it's the solution some common
solution so if the user ran some how to
draw and fill with some exceptions they
can instantly kiters get a solution from
us and finally is some low-level JVM
level analytics so basically we try to
catch some past profiling data JVM
profiling data and we provide some
people knowledge about that as well all
right so this is the what's currently
going on for thought heaven and if you
are interested in like knowing more
about that - we have some resources here
we have our github page we can just
search for that heaven that's the first
thing come out will be the don't happen
on github and we have a Google user
group people can post questions we have
some full-time team member working I
don't have a real response very soon and
we also has a blog posts that give a
introduction about that - and they also
has a presentation in height of summer
2015 you can find it on YouTube yes so
that's what I'm going to pretend today
and we can go with some questions
so it's a quiet time
so by default left which job finishes we
will save analyze and stay within the
database so user can search for their
job or flow and get a list of jobs they
are interested in to tune and also if
the user wants to wander war flow in
production they have to tune their jobs
so you use JIRA service then to force
the user to 200 jobs yes so the UI
basically gives instructions for the
changes that a user needs to make to
their job so I would in some ways
describe dr. elephant is like
performance tuning wizard but you know
wizard has a pretty bad name in the
software community so maybe it's more of
a doctor right and just like a doctor I
mean they can give you a treatment
regimen but if you don't take your pills
you know it doesn't do any good so yeah
for MapReduce traffic area from top
history server
oh no no no so top here's a server is
post set out REST API yeah yes for spark
drops we actually we parse the spare
loss because that at that time spark
stop history doesn't give a rest
I think I have a slide I'll give the
list of rules we have so
so this is our predefined rule for
mappers we have a almost the same for
reducer as well for matter remember we
have a data scale we have a PC if you
have time we have memory and so yeah so
this is like has been like tested and
improved based on the user feedback I
Lincoln so I think this has been like
tested and yeah so Tom if develop this
ruse we develop them based on our
experience like if you feel we should
make this user should like try to
improve based on certainly it's based on
our is privacy tuning experience and we
will modify improved
heuristics based on the user feedback
later so there's a plug-in API for
defining these rules and the API allows
each rule to basically select the
metrics that it's interested in and it
also allows the rule to configure how it
wants to display the information
probably in this case actually we're
showing a little bit too much
information to the user I mean they
don't need to know the precise value of
any of these numbers they mainly need to
know that like their job is sick and
here's what they need to do to make it
healthy again and probably the other
main thing is like telling the user this
is how much you're wasting every day or
every week that you don't have to
another thing also that most rules allow
you to do is to actually configure sort
of like parameters for the rule so you
can set the cutoff point that defines
where a job goes from being sort of
under the weather to being you know
terminal and since it is a plugin API
we've seen other teams that LinkedIn as
well as people outside of LinkedIn
actively developing new rule types
right so one of the the big motivations
for us to build dr. elephant was this
process that had been instituted I think
back in 2009 when Hadoop really started
to take off at LinkedIn and the people
who were running Hadoop at the time to
their credit realized that like if we
just let people onboard to the system
and write whatever they want it doesn't
matter how many machines we throw at
this cluster like it's always going to
be super slow and since also at that
time there was no real like solution to
isolate one job from another job on a
cluster we had to figure out a way to
make sure that the jobs that were you
know a mission-critical that had tight
SLA is that they actually finished on
time so we did what I think a lot of
companies have done which is you have a
development cluster in a production
cluster when then had to institute a
process for how do you get promoted from
development to production and the
process that was put in place involved
the job owner basically filling out a
questionnaire and then adding their name
to a waiting list and maybe a month
later you would get contacted by someone
from my team who would then say ok we're
gonna have a face-to-face meeting for an
hour and they would tell you what's
wrong and then invite you to reschedule
for yet another meeting after you had
made those changes and all the while
your job is running on the development
cluster only once you get the seal of
approval do you promote it to the
production cluster the really
embarrassing thing about this process
was that nothing prevented users from
then continuing to modify their job once
it hit production and we saw that all
the time
so whenever like you know completely
stable job missed an SLA or it caused
other jobs to miss out Cecilia's or
stuff like that that was always the
first question like who changed
something when they weren't supposed to
and the other you know sad fact about it
is that at these production review
meetings like you know clearly I could
have sent a robot to them you know to
sort of like answer these questions it
was all very mechanical so you know dr.
elephant is is our approach to
automating as much of that process as
possible so instead of filling out a
questionnaire dr. elephant collects a
lot of these statistics for you if you
wonder if you you
just create a JIRA ticket and we have
this agent process that runs and looks
at your tickets goes and looks at the
job itself and then we'll sort of
broadcast a health report on the jury
ticket and then the JIRA gives us a way
of actually tracking you know a paper
trail of the promotion process from
development over to production and
finally it allows us also to monitor
jobs once they hit production because
you know rather than locking it down to
the point where people can't make any
changes we feel it's better to allow
them to make changes but catch mistakes
early on cool any other questions yes
static analysis sir you're not talking
about exception stack analysis you're
talking about like each uh okay right so
there's something something that's
related to dr. elephant in the sense
that it's another thing we've invested
time in to improve user productivity and
that's a tool called by tray we're just
kind of like an x-ray you know goggle
system for byte code and one of the
problems with as given one of the things
that we don't like so much even though
the rest of the system is really cool
it's the fact that it allows users to
upload zip files containing you know
bags of garbage basically and you have a
lot of people using the system who are
not Java programmers that's not what
their job calls for right there data
scientists are trying to make sense of
data and you know classpath hygiene is
hard enough even for professional Java
developers but when you have a situation
where people are like sharing jar files
with each other and stuff like that you
can run into some pretty gnarly
classpath conflicts so by tray will scan
the contents of a jar file at the
bytecode level and it will find class
file conflicts when we migrated from
Hadoop one to a dupe two we were
confronted by the fact that even though
the API is in Hadoop one or in Hadoop to
our source compatible with Hadoop one
they weren't binary compatible so it was
this weird situation of having to say
well we need you to go and recompile
your job and then re-upload it but you
don't need to change any of the code so
at that point we actually send a bitrate
to modify bytecode so as a user uploaded
their job it would go in and look for
these specific cases where for example a
class had changed to an interface and it
would add a little bit of additional
bytecode to cover up that problem and
probably took someone on my team maybe a
couple of days to do that and it
probably saved a couple months of
aggregate developer time in terms of the
migration so seems like a good
investment to make so that's some sort
of stack analysis we do another thing
that we've started working on is being
able to predict that
is going to fail on the cluster because
of a class not found exception and we
see a lot of cases of people wasting a
lot of time when they keep you know
uploading a job running it and it fails
and this is a problem that you should be
able to catch with static analysis or at
least warn people of and then another
thing that we do is with bitrate we scan
to make sure that people aren't let's
say inheriting a transitive dependency
from Hadoop which may change when we
upgrade Hadoop and then their workflow
would fail as a result so were able to
warn people about that as well any other
questions yes
started working on that and we have some
in fact I think function yes so at the
alerting feature is Wow seeing that we
are actually walking on dog heaven so
busily if you be what are we planning to
do is we want to give the user the
ability to subscribes to a particular
job or what follows so if we if like
some day catch some of normal ease or
they can be the user can't get hit
so we are looking into adding those
features I think one sort of like
challenge that we're faced with is that
you know dr. elephant is in the advice
business and as soon as people stop
finding your advice useful they stop
reading your email they stop answering
your calls and stuff like that so and
and we know that we sort of can only
like lose the confidence of users once
and then it's pretty much gone so we're
being really careful to make sure that
we're not offering too much advice or
not offering bad advice but definitely
tracking how performance changes over
time is one of the things that we're
super interested in also tracking how
things in general on the cluster change
over time because typically when
something breaks my first question is
always what changed and when you're
talking about a multi-thousand known
cluster with more than a thousand users
a lot can change so being able to
quickly narrow that down you know to the
set of changes that may have some
relationship to your problem is a big
concern for us so I think currently in
that happened if you like if have one
draw we can actually see a list of the
historical hormones for the for the same
drop runs so really create any job you
can see and there's the link inside that
happen that you can use to see the
historical runs for this draw so this is
the current status and but I think right
now we are walking on live in providing
more insight for that including lighting
user to actually actively subscribe and
we'll alert the user for a second if we
can draw performance changes in the
filter yeah well I want to add really
quickly what I was saying before is that
we want to give users the ability to
sort of set knobs in terms of when to
alert me because we know that that's not
going to be the same for every user and
some people if they're working on
something that's like super high
priority needs to get deployed the next
week even if it is inefficient and then
they're going to come and clean it up
later we want people to have the ability
to temporarily turn these warnings off
another issue is if you build it tool
like this you have to I think accept the
fact that you're only going to get a 90
percent solution sometimes the advice is
going to be a little bit wrong you have
a job that's doing something a little
and that in general this should be a red
flag for you know having cancer or
something like that but in this case
whatever your immune system is fighting
it or you're doing you know something
weird or your bionics so being able to
like tag false positives as another
thing that we want to add quickly any
other questions
sure thing is a job inspection so right
now by code modification an intersection
happens at the point when a workflow zip
file is uploaded to Azkaban but there is
no reason why we couldn't actually hook
in at a lower layer like a job
submission time and that way we would
catch both things coming from Azkaban as
well as coming from other workflow
schedulers they are able to submit yes
so you can run a job from the command
line yeah it would not that is true but
in general things that people are
running from the command line in an
ad-hoc fashion you know because of the
way teams are organized in a sense
that's not our problem so we tend to
focus on the things that you know are
generating support tickets for us first
but also people who are running
workflows that have an SLA that they
have to hit anything that happens on
their production clusters is a scheduled
job that goes through Azkaban so that
was a way for us to sort of hit the high
priority you know use cases which
covered probably 99% of the jobs that
get submitted
so we should quickly explain what
support actually entails basically the
workflow manager needs to inject a
couple properties into the job
configuration which just provide a link
back to the easy project or the Azkaban
project for stuff like that and as long
as this is like a unique key a primary
key that doctor elephant can sort and
aggregate on we're good so so the
integration is like a fairly lightweight
process are you up to date with with the
uzi integration at this point we are
still working on to see who's going to
implement but it's in the roadmap we
don't have a definite date yet and it's
a plug-in model for any scheduler that's
how you see airflow has an plugin for a
doctor elephants similarly it's easy but
it's a work in progress and speaking of
that we should probably get that
documented on the wiki like here's the
process for adding support to a new
scheduler like pinball for example any
other questions yep
so these rules come with dr. elephant
and they're automatically applied to all
of the jobs and there's also like I
mentioned the plug-in API so you can
implement new rules on your own but
every all the rules that we have are
basically provided by people on the
Hadoop team right now at LinkedIn and
we've seen like a couple of cases where
some power users will suggest changes to
rules or will even sometimes submit pull
requests to get those changes made the
rules for spark were implemented by
another team at LinkedIn so that's a
sort of another example of another team
using the plug-in API and being able to
extend dr. elephant with it yes okay so
this is a good question to ask so the
the inspiration for to act like okay so
the motivation for dr. elephant was I
wanted to stop spending time doing
production reviews and watching people
on my team you know waste time and
watching people on my team waste the
time of other people you know doing
these production reviews the inspiration
came from this book the title of which I
forget written by Alex Holmes it's one
of the you know doop trade paperbacks
and there's a chapter in that book on
how to tune Hadoop jobs and on one page
there is a flow chart like a decision
tree basically of you know what is the
value of this metric if so then you need
to go in tune this and here's the change
that you need to make and I previously
randomly sort of seen these text books
that first-year medical students use
which have the same thing in them there
are flow charts for diagnosing different
diseases based on symptoms that you
observe and another thing is like if any
of you have ever looked at like
rule-based systems things like drools or
Jenna or some of these expert systems
that were really popular in the 1980s
you may be familiar with the idea that
like just by sort of coding up a bunch
of rules you can get a computer to
recommit interesting ways and come to
pretty cool conclusions based on a set
of input criteria so seems like we had
all of the the basic pieces we needed to
fit together
and we happen to have a really
productive summer intern that year who
we let loose on this and six weeks later
we had probably about 50% of what you
see here not quite as many rules but the
the basics of the system were there any
other questions
who's the one Oh
so that would be Jake reps sir yeah Jay
I guess was a Harry Potter fan at that
point and then I believe he became a fan
of Franz Kafka and I'm not sure who he
is reading right now but I guess we'll
have to wait for the next project to
come out any other questions yep
good question so the question was what
are the most commonly violated rules I'm
gonna pass this to funk she so based on
my experience I think memory settings so
a lot of people are increasing memory
about they're actually that they didn't
really use that memory memory is kind of
one of the interesting settings right
because if you run out of memory your
job fails and you miss an SLA so it is a
form of insurance right you always have
to provision enough for the maximum that
you're going to need only if you use it
some of the times so in a way it's not
surprising that that's the most
frequently violated rule and we've been
doing some sort of separate work about
doing a better job of of tuning
container sizes and responding them more
quickly one of the core principles of
dr. elephant up to this point has been a
dr. elephant offers advice it doesn't go
and modify your job for you because I
think for the system like that you're
you're going to make the wrong decision
some percentage of the time you're going
to get a lot more trouble for that than
the 99% of the time when you make the
right decision so this gives us a way
right if you know you can take our
advice or leave it
but do you know how exactly the
Hippocratic oath so from from this straw
actually you can see the max request max
require the physical memory is like 800
megabytes but it's you to user actually
requested two kilobytes container size
which means that I only use around 40%
of the memory they requested but why we
flag is a screen is because P of S is
our cluster default so if our car 34 is
now to talking about this this drop the
this heuristic will be flat as like for
a yellow or orange or red because that
will toaster get the user in this case
it should be safe if you set your
container memory to 1 gigabytes and
Saturday you save one gearbest memory
but but right now I think no I don't
think user will want this is class 30
fall in we were we are thinking about
like if we can like decrease it just
within we couldn't do that because we
operate a lot of grouse
the max physical memory scared from
cough counters yes so how do we provide
you of physical memory snapshot in these
counters this counter each task has a
memory snatcher of condors yes so
there's so I think it has a suite for
each each snapshot of each task has like
eight memory staff authorizing or twelve
so basically we we care the max we use
the max